here we go hello everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sockin and
today we have the pleasure sitting down
200k it's pleasure to be here hello
hello hello happy Women's Day I was
saying for me Women's Day it's 365 days
of the year so you know rah rah we have
a great show coming up a great
conversation Andra is the managing
director of Silicon Valley robotics she
is an investor an advisor and a robotics
ethicist so this is gonna be some great
conversation about our future with the
robots actually just a couple minutes
ago you taught me that 75% of all robots
are in places that humans don't even see
them we don't even engage with them in
those positions well it's a mix either
we don't see them which is where a large
part of the world's robots are today or
they're in places where we might see
them but we don't necessarily have
contact with them or we don't even
necessarily recognize that they're
robots one of the things about robotics
is that aside from the humanoid robot
which is kind of the apex in terms of
the pyramid of robotics and that's the
one that we've all grown up wanting to
have the rest of what is a robotics
technology it's improving and advancing
all the time so today we're surrounded
by things that 50 years ago we would
have called robots but now they're just
what we expect from our products they're
smarter products so let's let's unpack
this more because for for me
I think am a relatable example is when
we sketch things shipped to us from
Amazon yeah typically we don't think
about the actual warehouse and the
little Kiva robots that are driving
around the warehouse picking up the
packages bringing them over to the
actual workers that end up doing the
rest of the process
what that's one of them so many examples
of where we don't actually interact as
consumer consumers that's a great
example because that's a very recent
development in robotics and the large
part of robotics history
and robotics has been an industry for
over 50 years from the early 1960s the
first commercial robot arm with was
developed by engelberger and the next
iteration of that one that one kind of
trying to get my the order of dates
correct but I think GE picked up on that
and it became the next iteration of unum
8 was the programmable robot Universal
machine from Stanford this was actually
developed here at Stanford and that was
done by Vick Scheinman who and it became
known as the Puma
so it was programmable Universal machine
for assembling I believe if we get it
correct and that was the first kind of
electronically programmable robot arm
and it's formed the basis of pretty much
the majority of the robot industry up to
today and those are the industrial robot
arms and they are kept generally
speaking in cages or in factories which
are kind of lights-out factories they do
not have the smartness all the sensors
to detect if they're going to have some
sort of collision with people and yet
they have been what's underpinned
productivity in the automobile industry
yes in consumer electronics assembling
and in difficult and dangerous materials
handling so they do a lot of things like
welding robot welding and molten
materials molten metals handling and the
key principles for robotics have really
stemmed from those days which are that
robots should be doing the dirty dull
and dangerous tasks now what's happened
in the last 50 years and it's all really
kind of coming to a tipping point in the
last just five years really five to ten
years has been that these really
expensive complex robot technologies and
I will add that the other areas that
those technologies
jeez have been used have been what we
call the service robotics industry
sector so we've had industrial robots
and then the service industry has
covered things like Intuitive Surgical
which is developed the very complex or
about arms for surgery yep and so a few
people see them but they're very highly
trained and you know as a consumer you
won't be aware of that because you're
going to be out cold under anaesthetic
when you're having the operation done
and the other perhaps most widely
distributed robot is one that I just
love it's the dairy milking machine for
dairy farms and this has been pretty
much fairly well developed over the last
20 years and now countries like the
Netherlands and New Zealand are using
not just the robotic milking machines
which is a very intelligent ability to
you know kind of attach pumps and
monitor the the freshness and the
quality of the milk but also the way
that you get cows in and out of the
milking areas and that extends into
things like automatic gates back
scratchers and automatic feeders so you
can pretty much design a pathway for the
cow not only that but the cow can pick
their own pathway in a lot of these
instances so when you've got one of the
flee robot a size dairy farms some of
the things that they've found in studies
that the cows are happier and they're
producing twice as much milk because
with human labour we're really limited
to milking twice a day and it turns out
if a cow is producing a lot of milk
they're quite uncomfortable and they
would happily milk more frequently and
then when they're milking that
frequently they can eat richer food so
generally speaking allowing the cow to
choose when they care to get milked
makes them feel happy more comfortable
they eat better they produce more milk
so you get a real virtuous cycle in
productivity and
they have the backscratcher going on I'm
sure Ron or I had a backscratcher going
on us while we were doing our
performance here their exercise we would
be performing twice as we've already
done in or in fact the entire show would
be in front of the back scratches
yes back scratcher that's good that's
good so we just covered all the way from
automobiles it's pretty much taking us
up to today and the next area that's
seen a lot of change and growth has been
autonomous vehicles since the DARPA
Robotics Challenge --is and the DARPA
Robotics Challenge is were designed to
bring a technology forward to say look
it's easily 20 years out it's not
investable no invest is going to stretch
more than a five to at max 10 year kind
of timeframe so what can the government
do to bring technologies that we're
going to need further forward and get
them to the point where they're going to
be commercial so the first stop of
Robotics Challenge for driverless
vehicles was 2004 and not a single
vehicle completed the course seven miles
in the desert no one could do it do 2005
something like 30 vehicles
almost everybody completed the course
and then Google bought them all did they
really
yeah pretty absolutely Wow well maybe
not bought them all but what we saw was
it was already close enough in scope for
a long-term thinking company to buy them
yeah and that really put the cards down
so that most all of the other major
automotive companies started really
investing heavily in autonomous
technologies if they weren't already
thinking about it it got to the point
where 2014 I mean and by that time by
2011 we had both had a simulated urban
environment challenge and had leapt
ahead to 2011 having autonomous vehicles
doing test drives on the streets of
Silicon Valley yep and now I believe if
you go to the right parts of Silicon
Valley you can call up a rideshare and
it's going to be an autonomous vehicle
I haven't I haven't yet done that myself
likewise but it means that the
technology is coming very close to
commercial and we've seen this with
Tesla as well saying pretty much their
cars autonomous it's just getting over
that last little bit of do we really
have the regulatory and the social
infrastructure to support switching
vehicles to autonomy like what does that
actually mean and we've seen this a
little bit with the sudden development
of the drone industry and again we saw
that democratization of Technology
happen where a satellite a Space Station
something you know that it's exploring
Jupiter costs trillions of dollars to
build and you only really get one of
them a Predator drone costs millions of
dollars and there's only a few hundred
at best in the world and they're highly
highly specialized but then it's dropped
right start to get professional
photography level drones that are being
used in the cinematography industry or
being used to do kind of surveying for
oil and gas or other infrastructure
projects and they might cost a few
thousands of dollars but that's starting
to come into the range where you say
maybe as a hobbyist yeah I can afford
this or want this and well we hit that
tipping point a few years ago to the
point that I think a drone was pretty
much under every Christmas tree the last
couple of years because they're so
affordable naturally the more the
cheaper technology gets quite often the
smaller it gets and the fewer
capabilities but it allows a lot more
experimentation and we've seen this with
phone technology those of us who are
really old can remember when phones were
tied to the wall and you couldn't move
around with them and then when the I
worked in a TV station and I think we
had like the first car phones in
Australia because you know hey TV news
important people need to know what's
happening through a enormous release of
things
it's you know like I said it's just
living memory here and it's the 4000
bucks for one in the 80s for easily yeah
for sofa they what they were huge huge
absolutely huge and you kind of fast
forward and say you know 2006 the first
smartphone now in terms of figures I
believe 66 percent of the world's
population has a phone we're getting
there and if you in fact it's replacing
infrastructure in a lot of the
developing world so it's no longer
purely a first world thing and because
of infrastructure problems a lot of I
believe three-quarters of India gets
access to the Internet via their phone
not through any other well so the whole
kind of infrastructure step of going to
cable providers and through the phone
network like that didn't exist but it
doesn't matter went straight to mobile
technologies and all the polls on the
streets providing us with our phone
signals and Internet signal is again
something that potentially Africa India
other places in the world don't leap
frogged that stuff is in development so
we that was we're already so deep in
this we went you know the car well we're
really just getting up to the point that
you raised in the question which was
Kiva robots and what we're starting to
see now is the proliferation of what are
still called service industry robots
because you know here's the key a
service industry robot it's not in the
factory like an industrial robot
necessarily but it's not a consumer
robot it's not in our house it's a robot
that's a business robot basically it's
doing something in medicine something in
agriculture something in logistics and
logistics is absolutely a hot area right
now and it started with Amazon's
acquisition of Kiva systems and when a
large company like that says we actually
believe that autonomous mobile systems
will do a better job than building
effectively a kind of automation
infrastructure so that
the turning point there instead of
saying well if I want to get something
from A to B I have two choices either I
hire a person and they walk it from A to
B and we pay let's see minimum wages are
going up and we're physically limited we
can't shift the factory to Vietnam or
wherever the latest low wage country is
we're doing it here so we're going to
pay what it takes or what else can we do
we can invest in building a conveyor
belt that will continuously take things
from A to B and of course the downside
with that is it's expensive to put in
and it's really difficult to change mhm
you know what if you suddenly want to
shift it over to see it's easy for a
person to do that but it's also very
boring very tiring and it can be hard to
get people to do a lot of these jobs so
mobile robots that can more autonomously
follow different pathways that is what
the tipping point for logistics has been
and I see it as reshaping a lot of our
industries we're now starting to see
mobile robots attempting to deliver food
delivering small goods inside of hotels
and in FedEx is just starting to use
delivery robots we see quite a lot of
delivery robots in places like hospitals
and that can range from very large hefty
machines that are doing dirty laundry
and doing food trays and to very small
machines that are taking blood samples
to and fro the phlebotomist or the
laboratories now it turns out that
that's a very very high skilled job and
in fact anybody whose primary job is to
interpret lab results and give you you
know the the right results that's a
highly skilled highly trained job and we
pay a lot of money for that but to
preserve the quality of whatever they're
looking at very often we require that
person to be the person to walk those
results or those samples from the point
of collection to the point at which
they're being used and
that's a waste of a very skilled persons
time and this leads into one of the
areas people worry a lot that robots are
going to take jobs and that's not really
a good proposition to say you want to be
in a start-up in robotics and you're
going to need investment and you go to
someone and say hey I'm going to put all
these people out of jobs as an investor
you say well where's the profit margin
because people are cheap it doesn't
sound to me like you've really got a
good plan but if you come up to me as an
in and say look all of these factories
have trouble filling this job or farms
are wasting one third of their produce
because they can't get sufficient people
on the day that they need to harvest or
nursing stuff we're losing nursing staff
faster than we can replace them and
we've got a two-week backlog on getting
results for all these expensive
conditions and so forth and we can fix
that pain point and it's because we're
filling in the gaps where people aren't
with robots and automation rather than
trying to replace a person and we've
seen how stupid robots are I mean
honestly people are not going to get
replaced anytime soon but some of the
bits of our jobs will be so that is
particularly the tasks that are the
dirty dolt dangerous ones and the Kiva
systems in robots are doing that job
because the intelligent part of the work
is discerning if the objects are the
right objects and what to do with them
not walking the objects from a shelf to
the packing box so take the part that
people don't like doing out of the job
and then you're much more likely to be
able to staff the rest of the warehouse
so we're definitely gonna get into human
capital like you were ending with that
that's gonna be a great conversation
what's gonna happen it's
and capital with automation as we as we
get there to unpack so much of what you
just said
well I loved all the examples because
they are so close to what we experience
every single day and I think like you
said it started off with even the you
know the simple photo of taking a a
factory that used to assemble
automobiles and replacing it with the
arms that take pieces move them around
to the dangerous metals and liquid
metals all the their dangerous equipment
what was it dirty dirty dull and
dangerously dull and dangerous that's
that's that's very important and then
then we you know moved into your
productivity with dairy who moved into
productivity with other like logistics
systems with surgery systems that's with
Intuitive Surgical that's really
important and many of us especially our
grandparents our parents are sometimes
even having experiences with that
equipment and we might not be so aware
of it but now it's with the progression
into autonomous vehicles and drones and
all these other forms of technology that
are that are slowly maneuvering their
way into our existence especially in
large major cities where you actually
see the vehicles that are going and
mapping the roads homes on a daily basis
is it's starting to be so close to us so
you know looping us back to the initial
point now they're more visible in our
daily life visible although it might not
be directly in front of us they'll be
working with some of the people that we
know and we will have kind of a passing
relationship if we're I suppose right up
on the top end of the early take a
doctor scale then you might have a robot
in your house not just a robot vacuum
cleaner but some other sort of robot or
you might have one in your workplace
that you see but these are still very
early days that's I guess for me that's
at that end of the
spectrum and it's the social robots
spectrum end of the scale and we'll see
those in shops and in hotels and in
other places more generally before we're
all likely to have one in our house one
or two in our house perhaps even and
this is a really nice field because I
think right here in the service industry
you talked about robots for surgery
it's an interesting area because most
surgical systems are they're not
necessarily a multi-purpose what we're
finding is that each kind of part of the
body has highly specialized surgeons and
procedures and it really takes a very
specialized robot and you say well what
is the robot doing it's very much
augmenting the surgeon the codes in
medicine are so clear it has to be the
surgeons control all the time you don't
have robots doing surgery but why why
you use them is because they compensate
for my new variations and if you think
about it a surgeon can spend eight hours
performing an operation it's very very
bad in terms of posture mm-hm and it
turns out that when you operate say on
somebody's knee or I are part of the
body the best position to get access is
actually with the patient upside down
and as a surgeon then you're getting the
entire medical staff to try to operate
from underneath so those are things that
if you could facilitate something like
that you can get the best possible
outcomes and yet our traditional model
for surgery is the patient in one
position kind of flat on a table with
the use of robotic surgery you have
highly trained surgeons with the ability
to see what they're doing at a position
that might be quite different
to where the actual tools and the can
and it's such good fidelity in terms of
the vision and in terms of the haptic
feedback from the system that they can
operate from here when the patient might
be here and the operation is happening
here yeah and the wit so that's one of
the really great things about it the
second is so you're reducing the strain
on the surgeon and any sort of tremor or
slippage can be fatal some cases and it
can be partly eliminated through the
system you know if you Mark out the
dangerous boundaries you can kind of set
markers you can provide more protection
than you could and you can do this in a
minimally invasive fashion because if
you're only inserting the ends of the
tools that you need you can have a much
smaller kind of incision then when you
have to open everything up so that
people can see what they're doing and to
reach and to reach with you know larger
wider tools so there's the consistency
there's the ability to prevent fatigue
and era from the surgeons and there is
the minimally invasive kind of aspect of
it and you know even beyond that there's
the idea that once you start to
effectively add a digital layer to
something that's a manual physical
procedure then you can start to gain
information about that procedure was it
successful when it happened this way
and then let's share that information so
it adds another way of creating and
effectively sharing additional value yes
and this is one that's again very close
to home because so many of us have
parents or grandparents that are
experiencing some sort of pathology over
there are later years of life and what
the more important way to understand the
impact of robotics on an industry
then directly with the health and
longevity of a family member
that's really important there's so many
different variables you listed there is
so important and then dude do you have
another kind of interesting one that
you've been you know you were listing so
many as well with even with delivery or
certain fields so many areas that are
starting to no yeah delivering goods to
someone via FedEx roboticize to FedEx or
UPS truck I mean we're talking every
single field is being impacted by this
and we're seeing more of them so the
number is actually decreasing from 25%
we are increasing 25% of ones that we
see now maybe it's going up to 30 or 40%
of robots that we actually see can be
but when we look at a car we don't tend
to think robot ditto when we look at a
plane and these days most every new car
and definitely every plane is a robot
that just happens to still also have
drivers this is a hybrid though it's
capable of with cars they're not all
capable of full autonomy yet I think
technically planes are capable of full
autonomy they're like 99 percent or
something very high but we don't choose
to use that yet for other reasons where
we just I guess don't really have the
legal insurance and social
infrastructures to say yeah we're okay
with you know jumbo jets flying without
pilots I think that we're going to see
platooning when we're talking about
trucks planes and cargo ships wearing
what we see is that the first vehicle
has drivers and then the second third
and fourth don't they followed the
pattern of the first vehicle so I think
those are probably effective ways of
using autonomous technology and then
once again we might see it but we won't
go oh hey look at the autonomous trucks
will be just like oh there's a road
train I mean in Australia we see a lot
of road trains and it's a mechanical
now we're losing the mechanical linkage
in the same way that we've already got
drive-by-wire in all our cars so there
is no longer a mechanical linkage
between what we do as a driver and what
the car does that's already something
that is more like a robot than we think
we're tuning yeah so they'll be
following along digitally via software
without an actual hardware person moving
it along the other part of the the
shipping industry I thought was really
fascinating as well logistics in moving
cargo cuz 90% of all world trade happens
by sea via these massive barges and
containers so to be able to reroute
logistically barges to different cities
depending on the amount of goods in
those cities as well as just overall
taking the already crew of a couple
2,500 people and saying we don't need
the crew the barge can go by itself and
you don't need to be on out at sea for
this long there's a lot of examples love
love this it's so many different
industries how about we talk about human
capital then because you'd mentioned it
earlier I think it's really important
when people come in and come up with an
idea about how they want to automate an
industry typically people respond by
saying that well you said human capital
is very cheap how much is it actually
gonna cost to build out this hardware
and software to be able to replace them
how much money can be made after so many
years but one more time dirty dull and
danger dangerous dirty dull and
dangerous work that is they're typically
trying to replace is actually in many
cases humans prefer to do something else
creative work or some sort of other
problem-solving work that is more
dynamic that's non repetitive that's not
dangerous dirty or dull so it seems as
though it's becoming more and more human
capital is moving in a direction of
needing to be more creative and
problem-solving and something important
to teach our kids I think that we
I think that we need to do more
investing in STEM education but I worry
that we say that that's where the
problem point is and our education
system is a very slow thing to change
and we really need it to have changed
already but I think one of the things
that we can do as we saw with the
Industrial Revolution around the
automobile an entire population shifted
from the care and tending of the horse
and the carriage to the care and tending
of the automobile mm-hmm and it wasn't
that everybody had to suddenly skill up
there were comparatively gentle on-ramps
yeah in some areas and it might be areas
that we don't necessarily see yet
because there's not yet a huge demand
for people working in robotics well
let's say the demand for people working
in robotics right now is for highly
skilled people who can design build and
program I don't believe that everybody
is going to need to have a degree in
computer programming to work with robots
definitely because look at what we've
done with our phones and tablets and
every two-year-old I know is highly
fluent in operating phones and tablets
and I know that some of the companies
that were making early robots in areas
like bomb disposal robots oddly enough
one of those companies went on to make
the Roomba robot vacuum cleaner that's
so popular but they also made robots for
the army and I think one of their robots
was thrown out because it was too
complicated you opened up a suitcase of
all of the controls to make the robot
work and when they were showing it to
the army they just said ah this is way
too complicated for the average infantry
men to use come back with something that
works like it
an Xbox controller mm-hmm because
everyone can operate an Xbox controller
and the point was I think a really
important point for everybody building
robots
it's about usability yeah you know sure
you can build in all of these functions
and have all of these controls and the
thing is if no one uses it you get no
results out of it even the Intuitive
Surgical controller looks a little bit
like an Xbox oh yeah and it's a
remarkably sophisticated device but it
gives you feedback so that you can feel
what you're doing and how it's working
you know it just makes it very easy to
operate it usability yeah
the usability is the key thing and I
think that before we worry about we're
going to have a gently an entire
population that is going to be out of
not just jobs but out of the ability to
have jobs I think it is so so wrong I
mean first off every robot that I have
been around has tended to need a person
to take care of it and that's not always
highly-skilled operation quite often
it's Oh get it out of the corner again
it's not fitting properly onto the
charge plate see if there's something
stuck in the wheels I think we're going
to see pretty much a standardized job
for every couple of robots in the wild
is a robot babysitter basically you know
like a robot driver yeah just in the
days of the horse you know because they
kind of have minds of their own I mean
perhaps literally they do they don't
have autonomy but they operate in a way
that we think is intelligent that can
get them into all sorts of trouble one
of my robots is particularly fascinated
with their reflection in the oven as
they drive by and they're supposed to be
zeroing in on people or other objects
but that's sufficiently interesting so
that it stops Auvergne you're like yeah
no no no so there will be a job doing
that and there'll be a job
possibly controlling and getting the
results in the readings and just
actually moving them from place to place
because a person can move from one
location to work to the next location
and that is a highly sophisticated task
I mean can you imagine if you let's say
it was a cleaning crew a robot cleaning
crew well you're still gonna need the
robot Wranglers to get them into one
place and then move them on to the next
place and I think for me that's where I
see the human capital coming back in
particularly with the opportunity to
make money off your skills with robotics
now one of the jobs that a lot of people
will have had up to today is say
painting or sanding or testing surfaces
on all sorts of infrastructure you know
being strapped into belts and taken up
on the bridge on tanks on ships on the
sides of skyscrapers now most of that's
non automated work it's quite a
dangerous job and yet we have two people
up in those little pulleys up and down
the sides of buildings now what I think
is going to happen is that those two
people are going to stop washing the
windows and they're going to end up up
on the roof or down on the ground
driving the robot that's washing the
windows and taking it down when it needs
to clean and change the the pads you're
swapping the pads putting it back up and
then packing it away when you know the
day is over or they move to a new
building or a new job and I think that's
the key change that's going to happen is
it's an extension of the power tool if
you look at it that way so we've gone
from a period where we had carpenters
for example and everything was being
done with human power and then we added
power tools this we didn't really take
carpenters away we gave them the ability
to be more productive and to operate
more say
more efficiently more effectively by
adding power tools now what we're going
to do is instead of driving the power
tool by hand directly and you know
chopping your fingers off we're going to
give you the ability to kind of remotely
operate the power tools because that's
the autonomous robot you're you bringing
in this really important shorts the
short-term step that is typically passed
over you're totally right
also many conversations about robotics
and AI go on without even and human
capital go on without even considering
this step that's happening in the next
five years
that's a father step that happens in the
next five years is that humans will
still be engaged in some sort of way
with the robots like you said a
caretaker a driver to the different
destinations someone that looks at
overall the different data sets and
logistics that are actually going on
with the robot packaging up that data
making it applicable to people all that
kind of stuff still going to be needed
in these near-term years and so this is
the kind of retraining that we'll be
doing with human capital in these next
few years I think that's really
crucially important to understand and I
believe it's retraining that's going to
be doable that can be done through
online training through self-motivated
people what I love is the idea that
instead of you know making it this
really horrible retraining is to make
something really usable you capture
things that people already do or like
doing and I think there's quite a strong
element of video game playing in our
operations with robots and so you know
on the one hand you can be really you
can get a lot of status for your ability
to play video games now that's going to
translate over you can be really really
good at controlling robots and that's
really leveraging skills you're getting
having fun
so I think that there is some really
good opportunities there in the future
yeah you're so right
especially with video game play if you
like that's something that is about
augmented reality is coming up I mean
that's a really good way to get trained
into using a robot in a new way helping
that robot
learn over time okay so human capital
especially looks like it's gonna go
through a change where where you're
engaging it's gonna be a little a little
more of a hybrid sort of interaction
with the robot in the next couple of
years
what should we be teaching our kids you
said earlier you're talking about
education and stem being so important
how does the parent how does their
teaching style to the child and how do
the communities and the teachers how
does our teaching style change to the
kids is there 5 years old 10 years old
15 years old to kind of get them ready
for this change that's again a really
good and it's a really hard question
sometimes what happens is the education
system is too slow to respond to the
changes I think what the education
system does very well is it knows the
importance of standardized standardized
learnings I mean these days we all learn
to read and write and you know it would
I think it would be a great problem if
that stopped the correct okay I think
that what that does is it gives us the
foundation tools to learn anything else
in the future
yeah and the maths that goes with that I
think the key thing is to teach critical
thinking not purely logic but that real
kind of problem solving how do I know
that this is true or the right way to do
something you're going to be faced with
so many choices in life I think the key
thing is the ability to learn how to
keep not just learning but how to make
decisions based on the best evidence
that you have in front of you and how to
recognize some of the things that we
have cognitive biases towards and that's
where statistical thinking is you know
it's it's an element of math but to me
it's also an element really of
psychology you know it's understanding
why people you know glass half-full
glass half-empty why certain things will
make us think it's half-empty
and other things will make us think it's
half-full and we will make decisions
based on those things whereas if you
stopped and evaluated them you might
really change your mind so I think that
that kind of cognitive skill is key and
I believe that schools are doing that
and can continue to do that I do think
it helps if schools are showcasing
technologies but I don't think it has to
be an extreme rush
I saw schools in Australia rush to get
digital whiteboards in and that turned
out to be a technological fad that to my
mind was great waste of money often
schools get technology and they do not
invest in the training and the support
that's needed to keep them going and I
have taught robotics in schools so I
know that sometimes you know we do a lot
of fundraising to get kits of robots and
then an outgoing parent says what
happens to the robots we bought two
years ago and it turns out they're in
the back of somebody's cupboard and
nobody knew so there were all of these
things that if you don't have advocates
really active advocates within the
school itself then you have this
turnover and someone comes up with a new
program and it's like wow this is
fantastic and then two years later it's
forgotten it's at the back of the
cupboard I do think though there's been
a move to getting 3d printers into
schools and what I find great about that
isn't that they work very often at all
and I don't think that how do you say I
don't think they integrate into the
curricula hugely but I do know how
compelling it is when kids watch
something printing in three dimensions
and then if you can match that back to
the idea that they can be designing
things on their computers or phones or
tablets and you know you're transforming
something from an idea or photos in real
life into manipulatable kind of
information that can then try
slide into something that a machine
works on and to see that happening in 3d
is so much more fascinating than just
seeing like 2d printers printing you
know it's like type words have things
printed out it just doesn't seem to
carry the the kind of Epiphany and I
have to say I would call it an epiphany
I've watched people's faces when we've
done kind of Show and Tell days with our
makerspace and other things like that
and they're like oh robot robot robot oh
what's that
and it's been oh there's a 3d printer
right old technology really it's an old
technology but the first time someone
sees it happening it changes how they
perceive their ability to interact with
the world yeah and it's that kind of
shift that I think is the best thing you
don't need to have one in front of you
all the time just to change how you
think about what it's possible yeah
you're pretty well set it's expanding
the mind to new dimensions new areas of
perceptions of how to see the world and
how I can oh you can then impact the
world through these different
technologies and tools that we've built
it seems to be that having a parent help
a child that gain access to these new
shifts in perception these augmentations
ends up changing that child's
perspective for the better it can launch
them into this new age of technology
Ron question for you what do you think
about the progress with robotics and
technology that were currently facing
what do you think about this progress
with robotics and technology that we
have what do you think about human
capital being changed what do I think
about it I think as soon as we realize
that we are a magnificent magnificent
magnificent robot in ourselves then it
would it be so overwhelming I think
what's happening right
we are what we're becoming is we're just
revealing what we've already been sort
of like oh you will become God somewhere
written he noted did Satan like that
somewhere down when we took a bite of
the forbidden fruit I don't know but
that's what I think about this time that
we're in and who we are and what we're
creating in a robot with artificial
intelligence you know we have artificial
intelligence - we're not as smart as
weak they haven't quite unlocked our own
divinity we haven't quite gotten to the
point where we can fully actualize
ourselves in the full capacity across
all these different people in the world
so to Ron's point and feel like that's
something that's very true
and I mean there's two sides of that
that I really love one is that I
actually think that we have less
artificial intelligence and more
intelligence augmentation then that's
really the key of what we're building
and doing is that it's extending our
human intelligence all the time yeah and
so it's better in fact there was kind of
an argument back when the the term AI
was coined between is it artificial
intelligence or is it I is it
intelligence augmentation yeah and you
know I think intelligence augmentation
is exactly where it's at right now
yeah and yet one of the things when I
was a kid I was the complete rockets and
robot gig but my ambition was to be an
astronaut and you know what I
passionately wanted to do was discover
the first aliens and that's what I feel
that I'm doing when I'm working with
robots particularly the the robots that
are becoming social robots that we're
having interactions with because it is a
constructed intelligence that is not
human that is very different from human
intelligence in so many ways
and to me it's it's actually the perfect
practice mission for discovering a wife
out in the universe is too well on the
one hand we're creating this which is
kind of the divinity the aspect we're
able to have the tools and the dreams
and the ideas to do this but it's still
quite mysterious how robots work where
we going with them and the human mind
and this is a point where we can
whatever we building in our artificial
systems we can use as a model for what
happens in the human systems and how
they differ and you know this has
happened quite in fact all through the
last 50 60 years is we've modeled our
ideas of biological systems and we've
modeled them mechanically and then we've
seen how that works and we've revised
our models so it's a the whole field of
biomimicry has been creating machines to
mimic life and then discovering how we
have now a better insight of how life
works how the biology works I'm glad you
brought up intelligence augmentation
because that's really what is happening
in so many different ways and I think
once people kind of get that grasp of
how everything that we've chatted about
over the last half hour 45 minutes that
that's that that is augmenting our
intelligence or intelligence
augmentation and the idea of an
artificial intelligence maybe we should
at least touch on this because it seems
to be a topic that so many people are at
least wanting to discusses in 20 years
hmm what we're where do we see our
relationship with in general artificial
intelligence one that has the ability to
dynamically shift across industries or
across interacting with humans that can
take a goal and execute it creatively do
we see that as a potential existential
threat to us
and okay I think there's a couple of
things here I think on the kind of
loosest definition of an artificial
general intelligence I'm a bit of a
pessimist I think it's at least thirty
years out like definitely post 2050 at
least and yet I can see some seeds of it
in development right now but that's why
I said we're really at intelligence
augmentation because what we have is a
lot of niche artificial intelligence
developments and there is a
generalizable thread across them and
indeed what we usually mean when we say
AGI or artificial general intelligence
isn't just the ability to kind of
transfer knowledge from one domain to
another or to learn in multiple domains
and they're each important and difficult
steps forward but we in we take AGI to
mean also a kind of theory of mind the
sense of a self but I would say that's
still only one of the steps towards that
we need straight from going it has a
mind to it has autonomy and to it has
desires and to it's going to kill us all
and you know I think we have to kind of
back back and look through all those
stages and say we can probably develop
something that has a theory of mind so
does a raven you know but outside of
Alfred Hitchcock's the birds we're not
really had much of a threat from Ravens
knowing that you are a kind of a unit
doesn't necessarily mean that you
consciously also think about your
choices or desires or have that step of
autonomy and agency and then desire
motivation is something that's highly
biologically intrinsic to us and I think
there's no guarantee that
we have that in an artificial system you
know some people will argue that you
can't have mind without having
motivation and other people will say
those things can be separated I think
that we could get a kind of theoretical
mind without necessarily having
motivation and because it might not be
embodied or if it is embodied and I do
think embodied cognition is perhaps the
fastest way of learning which is back
the step before you know generalizable
learning then AGI if it's not a
biological body is it going to have the
desires inherent to it that make us as
people have such passions desires and
urges and then the next one is if it did
have all of that if it had a mind and
had desires why would they necessarily
be in conflict with us would they
perhaps recognize us at all I mean would
we be competing for resources I think
there are so many places that could go
where insects have very sophisticated
civilizations other different levels of
life are incredibly prolific and strong
and clever and adaptive yet we are
operating on such different levels we're
not under you know we we can operate in
parallel or in symbiosis and so to go
straight from artificial intelligence
all the way up to is it a threat to us
is making so many leaps I can't see a
pathway there there are so many leaps
totally agree like you explained there's
so many steps before we actually get to
that general intelligence it will take
us quite a while to get there we also
have a waste map the human neural
architecture and then understand the
architecture of a machine and the way
that it could potentially have desires
and all of this stuff that would then
give us greater insight into how it can
get to that point do you feel as though
the conversation on a
global level or even the the
geopolitical struggle that we currently
have between nations China the United
States in terms of how many people are
striving to be the first to achieve some
great goals and artificial intelligence
is this a naturally important thing to
have markets sort of competing with each
other for innovation that's a good thing
should we also potentially have some
sort of social contract between one
another to not to want to keep these on
closed-loop systems so that they don't
escape the software into the world where
do you stand on the I think we've
already kind of taken most of the world
on the line and it is very hard to
firewall so I don't really know how we
would address that I think that
globalization is one of our biggest
challenges though and that's really in
terms of our broad political and
economic wrapper we've turned into a
global state and yet we don't we still
have a very geographical infrastructure
and I think that's inherently causing a
lot of tensions I think we have got a
lot of a tendency towards capitalism and
microtransactions and our technology can
help with that but I still don't know
how that plays out in in the face of
this conflict between our kind of
current globalized pathway and as I said
our geographical infrastructure and
that's where Norbert Weiner said back in
1964 ish that the future wasn't going to
be a comfortable hammock that we could
lie back in and be waited upon by our
robot slaves but it was an ever more
demanding struggle against the
limitations of human intelligence and he
was the grandfather of cybernetics
of man-machine interactions and what he
saw is the limiting factor was the human
structure and the human
I guess imagination and intelligence and
I think that that's also you know a
limiting factor is also a governor
it's a controlling factor as well so I
think that that's both the positive and
a negative in both yes so this is good
this is so much to unpack in you know in
a conversation about ethics and economy
that I mean just even as simple as what
do you think the human intelligence
interface is going to look like in terms
of ethics and morality who do you thinks
gonna be programming that do you think
it's gonna be vacuole company do you
think you'll be a government United
Nations word I think we've already gone
well down the pathway of having
companies make these decisions rather
than governments I do think it's great
to see a sudden increase in the number
of international ethnic bodies of
talking about AI autonomous systems and
robotics and saying what are the ethical
principles and guidelines that we need
to consider and that this is being
informed in a multidisciplinary fashion
because we need to have the input from
law from policy from insurance from
economics but also from what's actually
possible and where the threat points lie
I think we have seen issues around
algorithmic bias and nudging nudging
both in a very little way and in a
really kind of steering our economy type
way so when we have algorithmic trading
for example and that escapes beyond
human speed of reaction through to what
happens when we embody the algorithm in
a case in a robot and that can range
from what does that mean in terms of
physical harm through - what does that
mean in terms of stereotyped
interactions and behaviors
and it does raise all of those quirky
questions like what if we fall in love
with a robot
but even before we get to those points
what does it mean when we stereotype our
robot occupations and we've already done
this with our voice assistance so I'm
aware of six major voice assistance
economically speaking in the world
they're all female ok and we were
trained for this even before when our
GPS voices you can change them but they
would default female and very few people
change them our psychological studies
show that we respond differently to male
voices into female voices and this is
across a whole range of ages and
demographics on on behold we treat a
male voice as having more authority and
we're more likely to respond quickly to
a male voice and we treat a female voice
as calming or more compliant so we're
less likely to be irritated by a female
voice but because of this there is a
tendency to use female voices unless you
need to make a command and I don't know
if it's like this all the time but I was
in London recently and the famous London
Tube announcements to mind the gap what
on every train ride that I was on the
female voice would say and we're now
approaching something Heath station out
south second station on the yellow route
and we'll be moving to the next station
soon and then the male voice would come
in and say mind the gap and it seemed to
me to be absolutely down the lines of
when we're telling you to do something
we use the male voice and when we're
giving you information and helping you
we use the female voice and the thing is
we've been struggling for equal rights
for hundreds of years now and we're just
starting to get closer in
many professions and yet we still have
vast pay gaps and still very difficult
to get women into certain areas like you
know venture funding or politics or
high-profile areas so is this going to
set things back because we're training
our systems to behave with gender
stereotypes and then we're repeating and
replaying all those gender stereotypes
so everyone's going to grow up with this
hole here can I help you now do this
kind of thing fascinating so that's what
worries me and I think it's perhaps one
of the mildest things yet it's the most
pervasive thing yeah
I'm totally blown away by that because
without even considering what its gonna
how it's gonna impact children in five
10 20 years we're just doing these
things I guess similarly to what we were
discussing earlier with people
automating this work we think it's gonna
be good for everybody down the line we
don't necessarily know how well it's
gonna do for certain industries what's
gonna happen with the first accident
with autonomous vehicles if someone dies
what's gonna happen with the first
incident where that's happened and who's
liable when the the software that's
parsing a an x-ray or a PET scan says
that there is something that's wrong
with the body when there isn't or when
there is something wrong and it's not
detected you know those persons it's
false negatives yeah and the most
challenging one is because these systems
are complex we're building in a modular
fashion so you'll have one company that
is doing for example the computer vision
and one company that's doing the
hardware and bringing it all together
and one company that's provided the
operating system and another company
that's per
provided the data training sets that was
then incorporated in the computer vision
that was then packaged together by these
developers as part of the navigation and
behavior patterns that was then put
together in these systems and how do you
find out where the problems were yeah
how can you even see them if they're
coming as modular you know modular and
proprietary kind of yes software layers
yeah that's also a crucial point so okay
let's let's go through some of our some
of our simulation questions we already
have but let's let's ask you about the
current state of so many people having
so much less than so many others so if
four billion people have about as much
wealth as the top eight richest people
this even though the people that are
really poor in the world are slowly
going up the it's really good we have
the eight that are kind of going
exponentially up with dog again
augmenting their senses with robotics AI
genetic engineering brain leases space
colonization all of this stuff where do
you see the future of that gap of wealth
and equality and what are your thoughts
about it I think that we're approaching
not so much an industrial revolution
although that is certainly the case but
we're approaching another information
revolution the acquisition of language
was such a significant point for the
human species and then the ability to
read and to share information I think
the political upheavals that happened
around the time of the printing press
and the dissemination the broad
dissemination of information and the
growth of our ability now with almost
you know almost universal education
we've it's ended the world
now if 66% of the world now has access
to a phone and these days that means
access to the Internet that last third
of the world is going to be picking up
on this really quickly you
even if it's only at one or two points I
think we've reached a point now where
the poorest societies have access to at
the minimum radio and television and
most likely access to the Internet so
it's no wonder that we're seeing this
you know desire to migrate to other
parts of the world if your life is
untenable where you live you've seen
that there are other alternatives and I
think access to that information is
going to potentially allow a lot of new
developments new technologies and new
ways of developing technologies that
could shift some of this you know
incredible disparity in wealth you know
right now we are privileged in a small
set of the population but I don't think
it's a given that you have to become a
tech billionaire to suddenly change
things I think that you know what if we
give the information tools to people
that have incredibly strong business and
inventiveness and allow them to start to
perhaps remake their economies in ways
that take better advantage of the things
that are still accessible as resources
and I'm using the word resources really
broadly I am NOT an economist and so I
don't want to stretch too far there but
when we look at where are their social
technological step changes then I think
that global access to information is the
real revolution that we are going to see
and I just hope it means that we get a
better distribution of the world's
wealth yeah I think so too I think those
people become more competent they
typically figure out that they want to
give back in some way shape form as they
become more wealthy they figure that out
as well so ok how about are we alone in
the cosmos what do you think about that
not if we build robots
and that's the short answer the longer
answer is we also need robots to go out
and explore the cosmos because it's a
very long trip in dangerous conditions
for people
so perhaps robots is win-win yeah so you
think yes send robots out to go to
explore for us but do you think that we
are alone do you think life has evolved
on other planets orbiting stars some
sort of life I feel like there has to be
life but I suspect it's so different to
us that we don't recognize it and I
think that I mean I would love there to
be human-like or you know communicative
all compatible type life out there I
think that would be so for me you know
that's my childhood dream I think it
would be an amazing experience but it's
also a really arrogant view that our
particular life template is the best
most replicable one it's interesting
because there are some people who will
theorize how when you're basing you know
a carbon life-form you are eventually
going to end up with something like us
as if we're kind of the inherent top of
the tree but I would think the more we
learn about our recent history the more
we realize that perhaps we were just the
most bloodthirsty of the branches of our
recent trees and we're doing a pretty
good job of wiping out all of our
competition but what that means is that
our mindset is flawed when it comes to
saying what does other life look like on
the other hand I also think that there
is signals in the electromagnetic
spectrum that would almost certainly be
sent out by any sort of compatible
communicable life-form and there's so
far no signs of those so that doesn't
bode well but I think until we've
developed some form of traveling
at or above Lightspeed the that's just
the shear time lag means that we can't
interpret anything mm-hmm there's always
a little bit conversation about cloaking
as well people figuring out how to clone
Louis electromagnetic signals all that
good stuff so how about the question of
if we're in a computer simulation what
do you think about that who would bother
that's kind of you know I just think
it's so incredibly beyond it strikes me
as a thought exercise more than
something with any reasonable pragmatic
likelihood then maybe that's an
arrogance there that I don't see but I
think it's arrogant to think that we're
in a computer simulation because it's
kind of wouldn't it be rather boring so
whomever had the ability to create it or
could it be the greatest thing ever is
to simulate a universe and then observe
how all of the different life flourishes
across the stars and perhaps I'm still a
pragmatist at the end of the day I mean
if I don't know does it affect me you
know is it it's I do think the Turing
test idea which is if you can't tell the
difference is there actually a
difference is still quite a valid way to
look at things and if I can't tell then
how is it going to change my world in
terms of my behavior yeah if we if we do
come up with a way to actually figure it
out I think it is potentially one of the
most profound things that we could
uncover but like you said as a thought
exercise in general it's really
important expanding the mind to new
dimensions of thought and thinking we
were discussing that earlier and how
important that is all right how about as
a last question what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
I immediately thought of all those
gorgeous pictures of space and all of
the other celestial bodies but in my
life it's things like being able to go
for a walk on the beach and know that I
have people in my life as well and just
the knowledge even without seeing them
yeah you know so everything from
observing the cosmos all the way to the
walk on the beach and having people that
you love that love you in life yeah I
think the the incredibly pragmatic
experience of being a person alive in
this world and to me being a person
means being connected to other people
and this world is such an amazingly
beautiful place you know I I like
looking at the stars but the world is
really quite overwhelming as it is yeah
life's too short to be able to see it
all in experience at all yes how about
we do one of these this is a little nice
little fun a fun box full of a hundred
questions I have a little guide sheet
here too uh let's see here do you want
to do sex love and relationships
personality and emotions friends and
family culture and taste work and money
travel life and death self or category
Wow
how about life and death life and death
okay that's the I kind of stay in
rowboats because I said if I'm gonna
study something and spend all that time
learning and thinking I want to make
sure that it's something that's a really
important question in life and all the
way back there just saying you know what
is what worthy of being and I and ideas
of what are the most important questions
in life so let's go for life and death
let's do life and death for me get the
kit all here we go here some of them
alright
all right we'll have you pick from these
okay what's the question
what are the best features of middle age
can we have a second read on that what
are the best features of middle age this
is kind of a little bit ambiguous around
life and it just throw that card away I
just like that I think you're
technically I'm middle chose that one
over and I think you get the best of
both worlds
okay you know you're young enough and
agile enough to be able to experience
all of the things that in youth were
totally confusing and amusing and you've
developed your sense of self and who you
are although now I find the worst thing
of middle age is the fact that I stop
and I count and I go unless we fix this
real soon I'm approaching the halfway
point of my lifespan and that's not
comfortable yeah so on one end you got
the beauty of youth and on the other end
you got the beauty of death and you're
trying to scarce scary let's do it let's
do one more for fun in that same
category
how could older people be valued more oh
that's a good one how can older people
who value more do you know there are a
lot of World of Warcraft guilds of older
people hmm and I think that's a super I
can't wait to retire I'm gonna totally
videogame myself you know but this comes
back a little bit to what I said about
there are a lot of pathways to
employment through new technologies yes
that can be fun and I think we've got an
opportunity to reframe what work is and
if the essence of being an older person
is that you are limiting your physical
mobility and perhaps you'll find Xterra
tea
those kinds of things then what if we
have technologies that allow you to and
I don't want it to be work as in slave
driving type work but things that allow
you to connect with other people without
having as much of a physical component
correct and things that could allow you
to have positive impacts on other people
through that where you might have you
know I do volunteer work I do some
things like that maybe I'm not going to
go and do it the way you can go and
plant trees or you know that's a manual
tasks but you know it's fun you do it
with a group of other people maybe we
can switch some of the tasks like that
to a virtualized environment or where
your tele operating robots or where
you're dropping in to respond to queries
that people who are visiting museums
have about something that's a passionate
area of your interests and you go look I
really loved you know back in New
Zealand I remembered this and you know
I'd love to be there but I can't
physically yeah maybe I can still
participate so that's a long way around
to say can we create a more
participatory lifestyle correct you
value older people more that is
beautifully sad I totally agree with you
even though the physical body may not be
able to be in those locations the mind
is still at least able to function and
provide some sort of engagement with the
world and shed its wisdom into the world
still so I'm most only I'm bored you
there and that is a really good full
circle to all of these great
technologies that we've been discussing
how they are being augmented through
robotics and through code I think that
some of the key highlights are even
though all of these technologies and Ron
brought this up as well even though
these technologies are proliferating in
our world it's still really important to
somehow Vermont remind ourselves to tune
in be introspective into reminding
ourselves what purpose we have what
impact we want to bring to the world and
furthermore bringing that to our
children as our children grow into the
world really important to like you
mentioned so many times figure out
exactly how they can be introduced and
have their minds expanded these new
dimensions of 3d printing and robots and
have them see it and then feel it and
then think about what they want to do
with this technology moving forward I
mean from the beginning of the talk you
listen so many fields that it's already
and we definitely recommend everyone to
just go and look it up see what Kiva
systems does in Amazon warehouse so see
the Intuitive Surgical surgical robot go
and get a little tiny drone for like 20
bucks at the store they're so cheap now
and you just fly out a little cheap
plastic when you go play with it and
feel it out see it in action Andra this
has been such a pleasure we appreciate
you so much thank you for coming on
thank you so much I have to say it's so
nice to chat with you about all of the
things that I think we're both really
passionate about which is help let's
understand where technology is going in
the future
with the goal of of steering it to give
us the best possible outcomes
exactly and that's why we have
conversations like this if we can get
more people talking about technology
helping steer humanity in the best
possible directions I think we'll have
more creativity more diversity around
understanding how it can do so and
actually bring that to fruition so big
shout out to you guys at home for tuning
in thank you so much again if this
contents powerful useful for you give us
a like comment subscribe share it with
other people become a patron or on our
patreon you get access to exclusive Q&A
with Jes live event info up ahead of
time exclusive content as well so check
us out on patreon Ron Vargas our
director and producer thank you so much
and this has been a lot of fun let's do
this again soon Thank You Andre that's
great thank you so much
[Music]
you
[Music]